chantal hébert à toronto tasha
kheiriddin à toronto où aller castonguay
ici à montréal bonsoir messieurs dames
bonsoir prenons l'histoire du jour
d'abord j'ai hâte de vous entendre sur
cette histoire du globe and mail qui
nous a révélé que le conseil privé à
réexaminer un certain nombre de dossiers
de demandes de réfugiés
qu'est ce qu'il faut comprendre de ça je
commence mon voile pendant qu'on voit le
l'article en images
je commence avec vous chantal à
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce qu'il faut
retenir de sa selon vous
gouvernement contrairement au message du
parti conservateur de pendant l'histoire
de la crise des réfugiés plus tôt dans
la campagne que le gouvernement n'était
pas autant pressé de mettre les bouchées
doubles pour
participer au règlement d'une crise
humanitaire comme il l'a soutenu mais
plutôt de ralentir le débit en se disant
qu'ils risquaient d'avaler des
couleuvres donc avec la avec l'argument
sécuritaire ça donc forcément ralenti
tasha le processus non salées ralenti
par plusieurs semaines est-ce que ça
explique le ralentissement pourrait dire
le fait que c'était assez lent le
processus des gens accusent le
gouvernement de ne pas atteindre les
objectifs que c'est très très lent le
processus on ne sait pas exactement
combien de dossiers autres potentiels
ont été interdits le gouvernement dit
d'ailleurs que c'était pour des mesures
sécuritaires alors la grande question
c'est vraiment est-ce que c'était
justifié dans ce dossier pourquoi
simplement ces dossiers là on n'a
toujours pas les réponses
pascal est que bien sûr le parapluie de
la sécurité on peut mettre beaucoup
beaucoup de choses en tout jamais il
reste que l'entrée et des immigrés des
réfugiés dans plusieurs dossiers a été
ralentie ce stage l ouest un fait puis
c'est dommage que stephen harper n'ait
pas fait point de presse aujourd'hui on
aurait pu lui poser quelques questions
pour essayer de clarifier certaines
choses parce que lui ai fait quelques
belles phrases avant un discours
partisan à vancouver là il n'y a pas
répondu aux questions il y en a
plusieurs qui suppose d'avoir quelle
expertise du bureau du premier ministre
du personnel de stephen harper pour
réviser un programme comme celui de
l'accueil des réfugiés alors que
citoyenneté et immigration canada fait
ça depuis des décennies en accord avec
l'onu
pourquoi est ce que le bureau du premier
ministre lui soudainement est capable de
réviser ce type de programme là ça
montre à quel point que le pouvoir est
concentré entre les mains du bureau du
premier ministre maintenant qu'on est
rendu à faire ce type de vérification là
au bureau du premier ministre mais c'est
pas alec aux écouteurs plus janvier
lorsque il répond ce que vous dites on
va l'écouter pour vient parce qu'il
dispose quand même pas du personnel
politique leur faut faire attention
c'est les fonctionnaires au conseil
privé mais oui vous avez raison c'est
rattaché au bureau de foyers sur les
côtes on vient et au sujet des réfugiés
syriens
notre gouvernement a adopté une attitude
généreuse envers les réfugiés tout en
assurant la sélection des personnes les
plus vulnérables et en protégeant les
sécurité de notre pays
la vérification que nous avons demandé
plus tôt cette année visait à assurer
que ces objectifs étaient respectées
le personnel politique n'est jamais
impliqué dans l'approbation des demandes
des réfugiés ces décisions sont prises
par des fonctionnaires du ministère de
l'immigration et de la citoyenneté
conclure allez ce que stephen harper dit
ces mots personnel n'a pas choisi
individuellement les réfugiés qui sont
arrivés au pays sont on peut imaginer qu
effectivement la tour la tâche est quand
même assez lourds
si on commençait à choisir au bureau du
premier ministre mais ce que son
ministre russe alexander a dit c'est le
bureau du premier soit réviser la
directive à réviser le programme à ce
que les normes sont en place or je me
demande pourquoi c'est le bureau du
premier ministre qui fait ce type de
révision là alors que la sécurité relève
généralement la grc du crs l'agencé des
services frontaliers pourquoi c'est le
bureau du premier ministre qui se
demandent si la sécurité est respectée
je trouve qu'on a un prix très très
large au bureau du premier ministre dans
c dans la gestion de 70 de cette affaire
va conclure la trilogie matrix que le
conseil privé qui est le cabinet le
ministère du premier ministre
semaines le fer de travail du ministère
de l'immigration où mais nous la
sécurité publique c'est quand même
extraordinaire mais ça explique un
mystère qui est que quand cette crise de
réfugiés a éclaté pendant la campagne
stephen harper a pas dit je vais poser
des questions pour savoir pourquoi sa
voix si lentement et pourquoi c'est si
laborieux c'est parce que la réponse il
l'avait dans son propre dossier il le
devrait et m
il s'en vanter parce que cet argument
sécuritaire il s'est tellement pajany
qu'il a utilisée dans tous les débats
puis il dit si vous êtes irresponsables
monsieur mulcair est rude autres vouloir
accueillir trop long ça semble lui il
était sûr que c'était payant touchante
au sol ben je le dire on ne sait pas
exactement les raisons sécuritaires et
c'est possible qu'on les aurait jamais
si ça relève de 6,6 sa relève des
services de sécurité on va jamais savoir
et là c'est c'est une question
auxquelles ils ne pourraient pas
répondre
alors pour nous les canadiens on reste
dans l'ombre dans cette affaire là je
pense pas qu'un gouvernement que le
vermont aimeriez être peut-être pogné
avec cette information comme ils le sont
aujourd'hui alors je ne pense pas qu'il
aurait pris la décision de faire
examen de ce processus s'il n'y avait
pas une raison on aimerait bien le
savoir mais comme je dis probablement on
la saura jamais et comme dit alec il ya
pas eu de point de presse aujourd'hui
mme oda aux questions trop de questions
sur le type sur l'entente transpacifique
lundi on a épuisé le quota je veux vous
montrer un tableau messieurs dames
intentions de vote 8 octobre c'est la
projection du site que les mordus de
politiques connaissent bien et qui
s'appelle encore events on a monté le
nombre de sièges parce qu'ils gagnent
sont rentrés demain
bref regardez c'est la première fois
qu'il met sur son site
les libéraux en avançant 27 sièges 124
conservateur 85 jeunes [ __ ] on va voir
projection en ontario 57 pour les
libéraux 47 conservateurs 17 npd et
finalement au québec dernier tableau 44
pour le npd 20 pour les libéraux 13 les
conservateurs et un pour le bloc
québécois ça c'est pas la vérité la sas
et de d'un travail d'analyste en faisant
un amalgame des différents sondages très
difficile à mesurer cette campagne mais
qu'est ce que c'est chez vous dise
chantage commence par vous aussi c'est
la première fois qu'ils mais les
libéraux en tête samedi que les libéraux
en plus d'élan dans le moment que les
deux autres partis monsieur a peu qui
réussit toujours pas dans les sondages
entre à rejoindre son score de 2000 ans
je peux rappeler qu'en ontario c'était
autour de 45% on est vraiment loin du
compte en interview que le npd continue
à perdre de la vitesse que le bloc la
plafonner
est descendu et et semble plafonner vers
le bas un rôle et quand vous regardez
ses portraits d'heure ça ressemble plus
à la victoire minoritaire de paul martin
en 2004 que n'importe lesquels des
campagnes qui ont suivi gagné par
stephen harper d'achat les libéraux en
ontario notamment ça c'est clair on
monte deux puis trois puis toujours les
trois semaines ça s'est accentué
oui non s'écoute c'est l'écroulement du
vote npd qui explique en grande partie
la montée de libéraux et c'est quelque
chose de phénomènes la lutte va se faire
maintenant on voit entre les vidéos et
les conservateurs surtout en ontario -
au québec et aussi entre les trois
parties mais on voit de plus en plus de
gains et des libéraux en
colombie-britannique aussi alors c'est
là où se concentrent ce n'est pas un
accident monsieur recruté à vancouver
c'est on voit que monsieur trudeau ici
était dans la région toronto c'est celle
à aubas concentrer la campagne et c'est
à cause de la montée des libéraux dans
six classes là alec vous avez à
l'actualité où j'avais un instrument qui
ressemble à ça avec d'autres firmes
voyager ses larmes c'est la nouvelle
mode depuis quelques temps on va montrer
le tableau ça ressemble je veux le
montrer
bon ça c'est les intentions de vote mais
on va montrer le tableau on l'a pas
c'est pas grave vous avez montré le
nombre de sièges vous aussi vox pop la
black il affirme avec qui vous faites
affaire
ça ressemble dangereusement à la hausse
et ses libéraux un petit peu en tête sur
les conservateurs
ouais en fait notre projection de sièges
à l'actualité qui est fait avec max
proclame qu'il incidemment la même firme
qui fait la boussole électorale qui est
un spécialiste du film spécialiste du
comportement électoral dit que les
libéraux sont effectivement en tête par
deux sièges d'autres projections nous
donne 130 230 en faveur des libéraux on
n'est vraiment pas très loin de ce que
tu voudrais être comme projection est ce
que ça veut dire en réalité puisque
c'est évidemment de l'analyse
mathématique essentiellement on prend
l'algorithme on brasse le boulier de
tous les sondages quand on regarde ce
que ça devrait en compter la réalité
c'est que quand c'est aussi serré on en
a aucune idée de qui sortirait vainqueur
on reparle de quelques sièges d'avancé
pour les libéraux 3 ou 4 2 ou 3 en
réalité ça pourrait être aussi du
conservateur et qui en obtiennent cinq
ou six de plus on est vraiment
actuellement dans une course tellement
serré région paris
on quand c'est très très difficile même
pour les projections en sièges de savoir
exactement quoi s'amorcer mais ce qui
compte c'est la tendance est la tendance
c'est qu'il doit aux semaines on n'avait
pas des projections de sièges qui
donnait ça parce que la tendance était
pas aussi clair que ça j'ai couvert - la
campagne de 1995 patrice vous vous en
souvenez peut-être celle que jean
chrétien a regagné majoritaire on avait
passé les dix derniers jours de la
campagne à se demander si ulcéré avoir
une majorité dans les films il le haut
la main parce que les chiffres souvent
sont en arrière des intentions de vote
hier on peut pas les sondages avant
qu'on voit la tendance s'affirme y
progresse ça prend un certain nombre de
jours mais dans le moment entendre sur
le libre-échange tous les efforts de
monsieur harper cinq débats le seul
parti qui continue à monter quand même
de façon signifiante
c'est lille b aux mêmes et aussi au
québec l'ontario c'est une évidence au
québec où si on sait pas jusqu'où ça va
aller
alors voilà c'est la tendance tâche à un
mot et alec sur cholet vous surveillez
quoi vous la dernière semaine et demie
en particulier tâche à moi je vais
surveiller la région métropole de
toronto la question du niqab et
ressurgit et honnêtement si on regarde
lol ça vraiment une raison de monsieur
harper de le soulever s'est dirigée
surtout aux électeurs dans la communauté
indienne de la région de toronto
c'est c'est quelque chose maintenant
qu'on peut vraiment appeler du doigt
brousseau pratique ce n'était pas avec
la question de la citoyenneté mais seul
et maintenant et on va je pense
malheureusement continuer de voir ça
pendant la prochaine semaine et demie
alec web un jeu très intéressant puisque
bon si on fait l'agrégation de tous les
sondages on voit que la chute du npd au
québec semble être freinée long autour
de 30% depuis maintenant plusieurs jours
donc au québec et la bataille va se
faire maintenant comté par comté
certaines circonscriptions à montréal la
course est vraiment le npd et les
libéraux
je pense à des circonscriptions comme
indique par exemple honoré mercier à
montréal mais ailleurs la course est
vraiment npd parti conservateur dans la
grande région de québec au saguenay donc
est-ce que le vote anti harper va se
chercher un champion dans les dix
prochains jours c'est vrai pour
l'ontario mais ça semble claque en
ontario ça va être beaucoup les libéraux
parce qu'au québec on va être capable de
se coaliser avec un seul parti pour
bloquer
la route des conservateurs parce
qu'encore une volonté de changement
parce que ça va être intéressant
c'est ce que chantait le disais c'est
que cette volonté de changement si elle
trouve son champion et si les gens
finalement 10 b entre les deux centres
mulcair est rude aussi trudeau là ça
peut débouler un peu plus et on verra
mais il ya certains comtés au québec où
le vote libéral est pas très important
je pense à la région de québec je pense
au centre du québec au saguenay voilà ce
moment là les champions entier harper
s'est pas nécessairement le même parti
pour lequel de vue qui vont pas de
vouloir à public en ontario alors c'est
pour ça que ça va être assez intéressant
voir les 10 derniers jours
messieurs dames merci beaucoup on se
retrouve très rapidement non pas demain
parce qu'elle aimait axe politiciens la
semaine prochaine pour une dernière
semaine de campagne électorale
merci au revoir au revoir au revoir